while we are living with
and in a new pandemic covet 19
other infectious diseases have not
ceased to exist
causing widespread morbidity and
mortality
it is important not to forget these old
infectious diseases
and even consider the possibility that
the old and new pathogens together
will be responsible for complex
clinical outcomes and further put
pressure on our health care system
lab roots platform will provide us with
a comprehensive picture
of what is going on in the field and how
we can try
to protect us from these disease
causing pathogens
while we are living with and in a new
pandemic
namely covet 19 other infectious
diseases have not ceased to exist
causing widespread mobility and
mortality
it is important not to forget these old
infectious diseases
and even consider the possibility that
the old and new pathogens together
will be responsible for a complex
clinical outcomes and further put
pressure
on our health care system
lab roots platform will provide us with
a comprehensive picture
of what is going on in the field and
how we can try to protect us from these
disease-causing pathogens